let's think about what else we can see
there are no zeros but there's a
discontinuity here so what does that
mean about what I differentiate down
here it will still be a discontinuity
very good okay so I'm gonna draw myself
you know a dotted line here now i just
made a conceptual leap and I wonder if
you can work out how I made it ok I knew
somehow that not only was there a
discontinuity here and here but in fact
an asymptote here will give me an
asymptote here how do I know yeah it's
like because it's going to remain
undetermined as a quotient so when you
and then in order to differentiate even
have to square the directors would so
the first thing I'm thinking is in order
to have an acetone we talked about this
before right in what I have vertical
asymptotes like this you've got to have
some function on the numerator and then
you've got to have like I don't know X
minus 3 or something like that if that
was it that was equal to 3 ok now the
second you differentiate this value do
you may you do your question rule and
like I don't know it's gonna be we'll do
it um what's me dash sorry V it's just
XP what's your dash was just gonna be F
that I thought I don't want to know what
is minus U and the V dash which is just
1 ok there's the view right up don't
really care about that guy what I care
about is this guy look there's the next
year they've done it shares the same
asymptotes there's the first thing
there's something there's a much
geometric argument I can make that in
addition to that to confirm what I see
discontinuing ok disco to use are not
differentiable that that doesn't tell me
that there's going to be an asymptote ok
do you remember when we had a look at
our there are various graphs like this
right that's also not differentiable
right but the gradient for this guy is
remember it looked like this I don't
remember that that's not an asymptote
it's not asymptotic behavior so how do i
know that this will have a derivative
that has an ass
yeah because like if the first graph as
a puzzle to its second grade ii can't
exist there already so you already have
nothing and then you kinda feel like
there's really nothing you're on the
right track you're you're telling me
about the discontinuity I had the
discontinuity cupboard but I'm going
further I'm saying the kind of
discontinuity I have is an asymptote how
do I know guys I'm giving you a big clue
all you've got is geometry can you make
a geometric argument form is because the
first derivative is getting client I and
then it but it gets to infinitely more
and then but the other one comes from
like a positive infinity and it slows
down okay good and let me let me just
repeat that in case you didn't catch it
all right let me try and make the
geometric I've you think tell me about
the gradient here you already told me
it's increasing its positive but what
kind of the positive is it like is it a
little bit positive it's super-crazy
positive and it's going to get even more
positive as you approach the asymptotes
right so here this Grady is approaching
infinity do you see that now tell me
that's to the left of the acetone tell
me about here what kind of gradient do I
had again be careful here stay with me
you 12 cuz remember you told me from the
beginning this whole thing is increasing
the place where it's increasing most is
that place I circled here and here is
also the steepest do you see that it
gets kind of shallower as you go alright
so therefore it's also really really
really increasing that's how I know
there's an awesome time okay i'm going
to shortcut the rest of it is are
running out of time i know in fact i'm
also going to have a horizontal
asymptote here rather than rather than
ask you the question i'm just going to
tell you why
when i differentiate right have a look
at remember i'll ask you about the
gradient here in here let's finish we
finish if i go catch a bus go catch a
bus otherwise I'm going to keep going
and finishing right into the role look
at the gradient over here what's it
approaching its approaching a straight
line which is a constant of some kind
yeah right like say one or three right
what about the great in here it's
approaching the same straight line which
has therefore the same Grady the same
constant so a lot of pressure gradient
one over here I must be also approaching
Brady one over here and you can even see
that look if he drew attention here it's
that if you drew attention here and be
there so therefore here is my next
review of damn this is what it's doing
is a classic error here is that people
draw this horizontal asymptote they draw
it over here it can't be it's not
approaching zero this is not flattening
out it's going to increase forever if I
climate greeting of one alright that's
that's slaughter but it still climbing
or hot or a quarter but it still
climbing is the important okay all right
let's finish off really quickly I'm
worried i won't labor the fact that
you're also going to get an asymptote of
here okay but now the zeros here are on
my face reader tell me about what on the
actual function tank there are turning
points up here right so i'm going to get
my ruler i'm going to draw up here there
will be a stationary point in line with
that up here there be a stationary point
in line with that okay tell me what kind
of stationary points will they be worth
it would come cave oh look see the
second derivative is positive everywhere
except for the asymptote so therefore
this will be concave up and this
concave up all right now what do you
make of this ok it's only easy bit tell
you easy bit i'm approaching an
asymptote okay I guess I'll approach my
ass mister that's easy okay now what's
happening over here and look at this
look at this that's a negative gradient
can you see the gradient that's what
this graph is and below the axis so
therefore I must be decreasing over here
do you see that decrease you cannot
scintilla no because it's an honor a
public okay I'm not going to get like an
oblique asymptote up here if I belleek
asymptote here notice that means that
the gradient as I go further and further
this way is just more and more negative
or ever so just climbs off it might be a
paramore parabolic a subject but I don't
have enough information to work out
where that is so you don't worry about
over here what's happening it's
increasing and it seemed like the
gradient is positive and it's going to
be a positive so therefore it's going to
do this there's my grabbing it's even
it's even about this axis we just not
yet now just confirm okay you can pack
up as I do this right but let me show
you that it convince you I got it right
okay gradient decreasing decreasing
decreasing decreasing decreasing zero
and look at the side here increasing
increasing increasing discontinuity here
in between the US Attorney it's
decreasing
using decreasing there are 0 positive
increasing increasing increasing which
part was this for Kathy macavity hook
it's all [ __ ] a hug it's all concave
altar because all of these are positive